When I was 16 years old,
I was getting straight As
at my fancy college prep school
and feeling great about all
the possibilities ahead of me.
So one day I walked into the office
of my high school guidance counselor,
and I told him
about all the exciting plans
that were coming together in my mind.
I told him how I wanted to move
to the great city of Chicago,
where my brother was living at the time,
and start a whole new life.
I told him I wanted to go
to Northwestern University
and build on my strengths
in something like biology
or piano or psychology.
It was all just a path that felt
so right to me in my bones.
The guidance counselor was this quirky
older white gentleman,
I remember really well,
in response, he looked directly at me
and he said,
"Well it's a nice plan, a great school,
but it costs a lot of money
and they don't let a lot of people in."
And that was pretty much
the end of the conversation.
I walked out of that office knowing
I had a lot of other support in my life,
I put the conversation to the side
and kept moving forward.
But it stuck with me.
And I would think about it
from time to time over the years
and just wonder how
that interaction or others like it
could really affect someone,
especially if they don't have
a lot of other support in their life
or they're not sure
what they might be able to do.
So I kept going,
I followed through with my plan.
It worked out really well for me.
I continued on
to grad school in psychology.
And eventually I found myself fixated
with studying the lives
and life paths of young people.
And in this work,
the problem I've come to recognize
is that people are constantly
made to feel smaller
than they might otherwise become
by the people and the systems around them.
And this really matters
because it holds us back from seeing
and reaching who we might be.
My colleagues and I
have also found, however,
that key messages at critical moments
can keep people inspired by possibility.
We've been conducting experiments
for the past 15 years,
testing how messages
that open possibilities
can change people's lives
by expanding their identities,
rather than shrinking them.
And when I say identities,
I mean, all of the ideas
that you have about who you are
or who you might be.
This includes the groups
that feel really core to who you are,
which we call social identity.
Like, your family can be
a part of your identity
or your race, your ethnicity,
your economic status.
But identity is more than just all these
ideas about who we are right now.
It's also your ideas about who
you might become in the future,
which we call “future identity.”
And all these different parts of identity
are constantly being shaped
by the environments
that you find yourself in,
by the things that you go through
and by the messages that you take in.
These messages can either
shrink your identities
and make you feel smaller,
or they can expand your identities
to bring more possibilities within reach
for you to then work towards.
So to make all this as clear as possible,
let's imagine together a specific
11-year-old kid.
Let's give him a name,
we can use my brother's name
and call him Reggie.
At the age of 11,
Reggie's moving from being
a cute little kid to a preteen.
He has got good friends, loves his family.
And when he gets asked that question
people always seem to ask,
"What do you want to do when you grow up?"
He actually has a pretty solid image
coming together in his mind.
He is growing up in a modest apartment,
but he loves beautiful homes
and has an eye for how
they’re designed and constructed.
And he likes math,
so he sees himself becoming an architect
and designing homes all over the world.
At the same time,
he's starting to learn more and more
about the barriers in his way
to reaching that possible future identity.
Everything he's going
to have to accomplish,
all of the money it takes to get there.
It's this part that we wanted
to tackle in our research.
So we've run experiments testing
how kids like Reggie react
or respond to messages
that open or close possibilities.
How does that change what they imagine
for their own future identities
and what they actually do.
So let's say, somebody comes
into Reggie's classroom one day
with a message to share.
And this is just like we do
in our experiments.
It's something like,
"Yeah, college
can cost a lot of money.
But there's this thing out there
called need-based financial aid.
There are these resources
and opportunities to help you get there,
tuition can be really lower, even free,
if you set yourself up
to get to the right places."
Our experiments show
that getting that message
changes how Reggie responds
to the question
of "What do you see
yourself doing later in life?"
All of the possibilities
that probably require college,
like becoming an architect,
become bigger in his mind,
and he becomes 30 percent more likely
to see that for himself
and give that type of response
compared to if he just gets
a message saying,
"Here's the cost
of college, end of story."
What's really interesting on top of that
is that the message
that opens possibilities
does more than just change
what Reggie imagines.
It changes what he actually
does to get there.
Our experiments show
that after getting that message,
he plans to spend twice as much time
on homework the following night,
and he ends up seven times more likely
to actually complete
and turn in a real assignment
the teacher hands out the very next day.
So this is all when
he's just 11 years old.
So let's follow this a little bit further
to when he's now 15 years old.
He's in the middle of high school
and still really excited about this
possibility of architecture in his life
because of the messages he's been getting,
opening the possibilities
and the things he's been doing
as a result of them.
At this age, he’s becoming
more and more attuned
to what we call different levels of status
between him and other people
and groups in society
who seem to have more stuff,
have nicer clothes, more expensive homes.
Ultimately, he's picking up on whose lives
and identities seem to be setting them up
for all this success
that everybody seems to want.
So what we wanted to know in our studies
is how are the messages
that he's getting at this point
about his own identities,
who he might be now or in the future,
changing the extent
to which it still feels worth it
to keep working
towards this long-term goal.
So let's say, somebody comes
into his high school classroom
with a message to share,
could be a counselor or a teacher.
Again, just like we do in our experiments,
but this time it's a message
specifically about his identities.
It's something like,
"You may be noticing that there are
some people and groups in society
who seem to have more money
or seem to be better set up
to succeed in life.
But actually those people and groups
that are seen as having less
and having to work more for things,
they gain some specific advantages
because of that experience.
That type of social position leads people
to develop all sorts of strengths
and skills and perspectives
and connections
that are really key to contributing
to school and society."
What we find and replicate
in multiple experiments
is getting that message
that you might be a person with special
strengths because of your identity,
leads Reggie to feel better
about who he is
and his chances in life.
And this is above and beyond
just some general positive
"You can do it" type of message.
It's the specific connection between
his identity and those strengths
that's especially powerful.
For example, he starts to reflect
and he realizes that he has to work a lot
to help to contribute to the family,
and he has to take care
of his brother all the time
while his mom is working late.
So he's become really good
at time management
and still getting everything done.
It's these types of realizations
as a result of the message
that lead him to have a significant
boost in his self-esteem
compared to if he didn't get that message.
But it's not just that empty self-esteem.
What’s again interesting
is that he becomes more inspired,
and he becomes almost
10 percent more likely
to continue working and persisting
every time he runs into difficulty
in a challenging school task or assignment
compared to if he didn't get that message.
And that increase in persistence
pays off over time,
it's connected to his grades staying high
or improving throughout high school,
which is very different from the normal
trajectory of most students' grades
slowly going down a little bit
as high school goes on.
So that shift keeps his goals
within reach for longer.
And it takes us to four years later.
He's now 19 years old.
He kept going on in school
because of these messages
building up his identities
and the things that he did
as a result of them.
And he finds himself in this exciting
and scary new world of college.
He's feeling a little bit uncertain.
As he looks around,
he's hearing other students use words
he's never heard before with confidence,
they're talking about their trips
to Europe and all over the world.
So he's really looking
for some kind of message
about how his identities are seen
in this new environment.
So let's say he's in
the dining hall one day early on.
He doesn't know a lot of people yet.
So he overhears a group
of older students sitting nearby,
and they happen to be older students
coming from a wide range of backgrounds.
And he hears them talking
about the financial aid they're receiving
and how they feel supported
at the university.
He hears some of them saying they realize
they're coming from homes
and neighborhoods
that aren't the same as many
of the wealthy students
who seem to be around.
But it's turning out to help them.
They know a little bit more
about how to handle the tough situations
that come up during college.
They know a little bit more
about real-world issues and topics.
He hears them say they realize
they're bringing more into the classroom
because of their identities
and where they’re coming from,
and that it's being recognized.
Getting that message, hearing
from your peers or the institution
that your identities are valued
leads Reggie to feel
like he's going to figure out
how to succeed in his classes
and get the most out of college.
Our experiments show that getting
that message at the right time
bolsters him so much
that he then engages in college
in ways that throughout his first year
lead his grades to improve
compared to if he didn’t get that message.
So much so, that he ends his first year
with grades that are just as high
as students coming
from those wealthy backgrounds
and well-known private schools,
reducing the disparity between him
and those other students
by over 60 percent.
These are robust effects
that we find in experiments
where we randomly assign students
to receive these messages or not.
But there's a wrinkle in all of this.
All of these messages, they help so much,
they keep somebody seeing
and reaching towards tough goals
that can pay off in life,
but it can take a lot from you
to constantly persist
and overcome barriers.
And as Reggie reaches his dream job
at a top architecture firm
or in whatever field
he discovers along the way,
he realizes that he's feeling
kind of stressed all the time.
He's even getting physically ill
a little bit more often.
This is because to make it this far,
he's had to be extraordinarily
vigilant and persistent.
He's had to overcome barriers
in schools and workplaces
that aren't designed for people
without a lot of family wealth.
He's had to deal with constant experiences
of prejudice and discrimination
in settings that aren't used to
seeing someone like him succeed.
We published a review of dozens
of academic articles and empirical studies
showing that this type of experience
takes a toll on the physical health
of people like Reggie
and leads him to have an increase
in levels of inflammation in the body,
which is normally a natural response
to something like a threat from a virus.
But it becomes harmful
and over time leads him to have
an increased risk of heart disease,
cancer, chronic long-term illness
compared to if he weren't
striving in this way.
So in the end, is it even all worth it?
Well, I do think that it is,
because our experiments,
in collaboration with health research labs
show that there are ways for him
to work towards these goals
and maintain his health at the same time.
Let's go back to when he's in college,
overhearing that group
of students talking.
And say he actually is able
to jump over to connect
and make that new group of friends.
Or he's able to join
some community or organization,
like many that we work on,
that's established to help him
form deep and meaningful bonds
with people who may have some shared
identities and experiences
and backgrounds
that they explore together.
Or he's able to also
hold on to connections
in the places that he calls home
with the people that he calls family
and with the culture that matters to him.
All of these social connections
and relationships
are essential for physical health.
We've run experiments in collaboration
with health research labs
where we randomly assign
young people to get a message
that encourages them and shows them
how to cultivate and maintain
these types of relationships
while they're striving for these goals,
taking them to new places,
compared to a message
only focused on achievement.
And what we find when we bring
these participants back into the lab
is that over the course of a year,
that increased emphasis
on connection and relationships
leads to a decrease
in inflammation of 25 percent.
So by not only expanding his identities
but also keeping them connected
to close relationships,
Reggie is able to find achievement
and health at the same time.
Now my actual brother Reggie
had a very different life path
than the imaginary 11-year-old kid
that we just followed.
His life ended when he was struck
and killed by a drunk driver
almost exactly 10 years ago.
He was just a couple of years
older than I am now.
I really looked up to the life
that he was able to build.
It was full of joy and community
and success, doing what he loved.
But he had to find all of that
despite not receiving any of these
messages we've talking about in schools,
building up his identities
or opening possibilities.
I never had the chance to ask him
how he felt about all of that.
If there were any possibilities
he felt like he'd let go of
or if it all just seemed harder
than it needed to be to find his way.
What if these schools and systems
that we’re in as we’re growing up
actually supported everyone's
vision and potential?
What if they actually
encourage people to see
that there is a path to the goals
that they're working towards
and that there are ways
that the circumstances of their lives,
whatever they may be,
are setting them up for success
as they see it,
building up their identities
rather than shrinking them.
These types of messages can be embedded
in the ways that we teach important
and challenging topics
in areas like science,
language, math, the arts, history.
They can be central
to out-of-school activities,
like mentoring programs
and enrichment programs.
These messages
can be backed up by the policies
that are necessary to make
the financial resources
that you need to reach these goals
actually available for every kid,
without taking on crippling debt.
In the meantime,
as we continue to push
for the systemic changes
that would be necessary to make
these types of messages just feel common,
we also each have power as individuals.
I'm thinking about you as parents,
as coworkers, as leaders, as friends,
taking the time to show someone
that you see who they are,
you see who they could be
and that there is a path to the life
that they're imagining for themselves.
That message from you could lead someone
to hold on to what keeps them going
for just one more day.
Thank you.
(Applause and cheers)